[Music]
on monday right after the show we were
radio only we had talked about our
report that jim harbaugh
is going to be pursued by the jets the
just issued this statement todd bowles
is our head coach there is no truth to
the report of our interest in jim
harbaugh i retweeted that with the line
we stand by our report somebody
responded by saying time for the
unfollow so i responded by saying time
for the block i don't think this person
unfollowed me and i don't think i
blocked him but i just anytime somebody
threatens to unfollow me if i notice it
i'll i'll threaten to block them i mean
i don't care if you want to follow pft
follow pft if you don't don't i don't
care we provide a service either way and
at this time we're going to provide our
weekly service of airing some and says
chris as always you get to go first okay
well i got a i got two especially that i
want to get off my chest i think the
first one is this and i just been
hearing this too much over the last week
uh or really especially the last few
days since sunday night football again
it's come up and it just bothers me okay
and uh i got to get it off my chest and
it protects you don't get it go ahead
and get it off your chest it pertains to
the mvp of football which is patrick
mahomes okay first of all i'm sick of
the conversation he's so clearly the mvp
of football this year i don't know what
to say he's been the most special guy in
the game week in and week out so special
that we've had weeks where he throws
four touchdown passes and 350 yards and
we just go hey i've seen better that's
how special it's become but i'm so sick
of oh
he hasn't won the big game or his
performance in these big games is going
to be enough to knock him out well i
don't understand that or i just don't
get it first of all in the big games
we're talking about we're talking about
the four losses you mean on the road to
the patriots on the road to the seahawks
on the road to the rams uh okay two of
the better teams in football one of the
toughest environments and yes he lost
the chargers who are also one of the
best teams in football i get that uh in
those games it's 15 touchdowns six
interceptions you know
in those games especially the last two
there's no kareem hunt there's no sammy
watkins let me remind everybody sammy
watkins is being paid the same amount as
odell beckham jr he's not there but all
i'm saying is the guy is clearly the mvp
and special football and out of those
games we're talking about like
some of his worst performances of the
year are like the seventh or eighth best
performances of the year for a drew
brees so that's how it compares so i'm
not trying to sit here and hate on drew
brees all i'm trying to say is i don't
understand some of the factors that are
being thrown at patrick mahomes for the
reason he shouldn't win the mvp um yes
drew brees hasn't played well either as
of late and they've won some football
games not because of him but because of
their defense their run game things like
that last week was better i understand
that he played very well against
pittsburgh's dealers but i just don't
like the fact that we're going to use
the four losses on patrick mahomes all
the time to dictate the mvp race when
he's done special things all year long
and he did special things in those four
losses and we're gonna blame him for the
four losses even though they have the
worst defense in football and not a
running game and their secondary can't
stop anybody so that's why i wanted to
say that i just had to get it off my
chest one more time mike sorry
what if the chiefs lose at home sunday
to the raiders and end up not winning
the afc west doesn't your argument get
get weakened considerably for mvp if the
guy doesn't even win his own division
well what if he throws her five
touchdowns and 400 yards you're gonna
you're gonna see that that's the
offensive player of the year well what
was he he has nothing he's still the mvp
i mean why would that change anything
he's done everything he can possibly do
here's the problem we don't know what
the mvp is because there's no consensus
definition of what mvp is no it's
because it's become the media most
popular guy on the best team award
that's what it should be called it's no
longer all right well if you're a five
seed in the afc how are you the best
team
i i i'm saying that's what's the problem
with the award yeah we made it the most
popular guy on the best team award every
year it doesn't matter you're the mvp
because you're the most popular and
you're the best team mvp it's the same
thing every year it's stupid it's
disgusting patrick mahomes is the mvp
this year it's not even close to me
that's all i'm trying to say i did for
me and i know i might be wrong but i'm
just saying i don't think there's
anybody in a close second right now
except for maybe aaron donald if he
broke the sack record this weekend
all i know is this and and you know how
i feel about power yeah i know you love
them and and i was i was on board with
the patreon homes hype train before it
even pulled out of the station initially
right but when you have these high
profile games
and you're not delivering victories at
some point it falls on the quarterback
to at the right moment in the right spot
to have that big drive instead of making
the sidearm throw that wows everybody
just get down the field score and
deliver the victory
every time they lose the defense messes
it up that's what i want to well you
know he can't be out there and play
defense either when he's had the ball
last they win
when he hasn't they've lost
yeah i know that was a good one that was
a good point chris you're right chris
very good i just i just think i have a
hard time getting behind mvp if they
don't win the division now i expect them
to beat the raiders on sunday but if
they don't win the division it's much
harder to say that he's the mvp yeah
the raiders this weekend that's that
would be a very bad look and i can
understand the media turning against him
yes but you know again i think we're
we're blaming some of his losses and
it's the worst second to worst pass
defense in football second to worst
defense in football they really can't do
anything on that side of the ball it's
it's all on patrick mahomes which is the
epitome of the mvp hey we can't run we
can't do anything except you make
amazing plays and that's why we are
where we are can you deliver for us
again and oh you're down by seven
against the best defense in football the
baltimore ravens and they were pretty
good oh no big deal i'll go down and
score touchdown coach tie the game we'll
win in overtime delivered you know
that's that's why he's the mvp in my
eyes i know i'm getting emotional about
it but i feel passionate about it
i have a feeling we're going to have a
repeat of 1997 and 2000.
split champions yes 25 votes for patrick
mahomes and 25 votes for drew brees
that's what i think is gonna happen okay
and it's we spend so much time obsessing
over this the entire process is flawed
you've got 50 people
some of whom cover one team so they
don't even study the entire league at
large and there there isn't a first
place second place third place vote like
the heisman it's just one vote per
person and i i it's and and also we find
out the night before the super bowl
where we don't care at all about you're
right i don't know
i
i'm just like okay great let's get to
the game tomorrow now and move on you're
right
i have i have a grievance and and this
one may not be a popular one but i don't
care
um and i love larry fitzgerald
first ballot hall of famer he falls into
that category for me of guy who's going
to be successful at anything he ever
tries and there aren't many guys who
fall into that peyton manning drew brees
larry fitzgerald are the three right now
and i guess you got to put tom brady in
there too but
but i don't know what i don't i just i
feel it more strongly with manning brees
and fitzgerald but the video that
surfaced over the weekend of and
dominican sioux cramming his finger into
larry fitzgerald's eye for fitzgerald to
come out and say that it was just two
guys clowning around it wasn't
i i mean do not insult our intelligence
by suggesting that this is just two guys
goofing around he stuck his finger in
his eye you see him jam his finger in
there it's classic and domican sue doing
in dominican sioux things why are you
taking up for him i don't get that one
chris yeah i i get you there i tried to
figure out the history you know even
looking throughout the game and just
little clips like just to see was there
some joking going on between the two uh
but i i don't know where did you see
anything no did you see anything
no i can't i mean was it like a three
hour a three hour three stooges uh
cartoon or whatever that was shorts five
minutes short not exactly but uh i mean
i'm with you yeah i don't know what
larry fitzgerald's motivation is there
other than i guess he just didn't want
to see a guy that he must have some
relationship with off the field he
didn't want to see him get publicly
criticized and let it have it snowball
and make it worse than what it was so uh
i don't know i'm bowing to larry
fitzgerald here it certainly seemed odd
i'll say that it did not seem like the
video i saw that it was a joking around
type of thing i mean i obviously you
didn't think so either so um yeah i
can't say that i totally get that one
wanted to address the video circulating
from sunday fitzgerald said on wednesday
i've known and dominican sue since its
college days and he's a close friend of
mine quality as a person matches his
quality as a player that video is just a
friend clowning with another friend no
negative intent it's all love look that
would be all persuasive if we didn't
know what we know about the history of
endowment consume not clowning around
with others whether he's stomping on the
arm of evan dietrich smith whether he's
stepping on the leg of aaron rodgers and
claiming it's because his feet were cold
he didn't know where he was stepping
whether it's pushing his foot into the
crotch of matt shaub on thanksgiving
several years ago when he got fined he
got fined for all of those he got
suspended for the stomp on evan dietrich
smith he had a hundred thousand dollar
fine for taking out john sullivan's
knees in a game unnecessarily i mean
this is a guy who has a history of doing
these kinds of things and and this this
statement from larry fitzgerald is so
over the top it almost comes off as
passive aggressive to me yeah uh
yes it's like there's something more to
that motive there that he's sticking up
whether i don't know do they have the
same agent maybe that's where i should
have looked at is there something like
that that he's sticking up for him uh
either way i don't know it is very odd
uh all together that he came out with
such a strong uh a statement opposing
this whole thing but whatever i'm gonna
take his word for it i don't know what
other what other way to say it or put it
um all right i'm gonna go to my next one
is that okay with you
yeah it's fine with me all right good
here we go
um
i gotta it's a grievance okay i wanna be
careful here because i always respect
anybody's decision to do of course what
they like with their own life but here
we go i just got to point it out and
this is to a college kid i'm talking
about justin herbert up at oregon right
who just decided to stay in uh a school
for one more year and again i'm not
going to ever try to argue or tell a guy
what to do with his life but here i am
i'm gonna tell him to do what to do with
his life okay i just think it's a
incredibly risky decision for a guy okay
who i look at is going man he's got big
time starting nfl potential he could be
a superstar i think he would be a top
five pick in the nfl draft and i look at
that to go back to school to risk it to
be
around a bad team okay and then not have
a good year next year and be knocked out
of the top ten or knocked out of the top
20.
again i just look at it like this you
only have one chance to play in the nfl
you only have a certain amount of
allotted years to where you could play
and not only capitalizing your talents
but capitalize financially as well and i
think you're mate taking a tremendous
risk when you have a chance to go be the
guy be the face of the franchise and
when you are the face of the franchise
you basically get nine lives you get so
many chances to fail because they want
to make it work and we've seen that
across the board you know oh he's our
top 10 pick we're going to give him four
chances five chances six chances
whatever it may be and here he is a guy
who's going back to school as an athlete
too who runs around and kind of plays
the position somewhat physically i just
think he's risking a lot
again
i understand why he's going back but i
just got to throw it out there because i
think it's the wrong business decision
in this in this uh in this conversation
like i said you just you don't know how
things can go out everyone told me matt
barkley was going to be the number one
pick in the draft oh matt barkley number
one pick of the draft he went back to
school usc wasn't as good his play
wasn't as good and man he ended up a
middle rounder so i just think you're
taking a lot of risk there in a lot of
different situations and that's why i
say it
yeah and i agree with you completely
look these kids are entitled to make
business decisions i'm just always
concerned when they make the decision
when the nfl is ready for them when they
make the decision to stay in school
who's influencing right who who and and
and are the people who are talking to
them being candid as they need to be and
anyone who criticizes le'veon bell for
sitting out a full year and giving up
14.5 million needs to feel the same way
about justin herbert because when the
nfl is ready for you you need to get in
the nfl and get the clock ticking
on your next contract and the next
contract after that and it's not just
the money you lose your rookie year it's
that first shot at getting the
life-changing money you're delaying that
process and you're adding more risk into
the equation first i i beg and plead
with the nfl the christmas eve night
games have to go last year we didn't
have one on nbc we had our game on
saturday night
this year monday night football they had
that night game on christmas eve it
generated the lowest rating in the
history of monday night football
christmas eve night football does not
work you do not have a captive audience
people don't gather around the tv on
christmas eve they just don't it's not
like thanksgiving on christmas eve
people have things to do whether they're
at church whether they're around the
christmas tree opening presents whether
they're eating the seven fishes like the
italians my people do that's what i was
doing
and you don't especially when it's a
terrible game and you're always running
the risk it's going to be a bad game
because you don't know in april what's
going to hold up in late december okay
well do we have any like good games to
go off of on christmas eve there because
i mean i think that's why why would you
want to do that though why would you
want to have that when you when when
that is a night when you are doing other
things with family with friends going to
church or whatever
do you want to really have that dilemma
where there's a great game the game of
the week happens to be christmas eve at
night i just think that there has to be
a way to maneuver around that and i
really hope the nfl spurred by the very
low ratings the record low monday night
football ratings they realize this is
just not something that should be done
it is a tough night i will say that
there is a lot of course there's family
everything going on like that uh so yeah
i definitely wouldn't to your point want
the best game of the year or the best
game of the week on christmas eve night
i understand that completely i do think
though the fact that it was the raiders
and they're a crap hole right now and
denver has nothing exciting about their
team of course has to lead to the
historically bad ratings but i want to
hear your other grievance too go ahead
get your other one
well your good friend aaron rodgers
after the packers beat the jets on
sunday had this to say about joe philbin
we want to play for joe and give him the
best opportunity possible to be the the
full-time head coach and i i know what
aaron's trying to do chris and i don't
like it you know he's not going to have
an official role in the process but he's
making his voice
known and uh he wants joe philbin and
that would tend to potentially scare
away some viable candidates who are
going to think hey aaron rodgers doesn't
want me maybe i don't want the packers
yeah it is a little scary i don't love
it either just because you know you know
my thoughts on this it's still going to
be the same crappy offense and issues
you'll have there with joe philbin as
the head coach because he runs the same
offense mike mccarthy did so that's
where i have issues and it makes me
wonder to something i saw you write
yesterday that you know rogers
wants the old staff or regime there to a
degree because
maybe he can hold his power over people
still there i don't know those are
things that went through my mind and i
saw you wrote that on pft yesterday and
i thought those were good points
well and they've interviewed jim
caldwell and chuck pagano and i think
jim caldwell would be a great candidate
when you consider all the years he
worked with peyton manning the years he
worked with matthew stafford and the two
years in baltimore one of those years as
quarterbacks coach and then offensive
coordinator late in the year the ravens
won the super bowl and joe flacco won
the super bowl mvp award so maybe
caldwell's the right guy to work with
aaron rodgers for the final five years
of his career
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports